oi meu nome é pedro tenho 10 anos de
estudo no 5º ano
hoje eu estou aqui para falar como
desmatamento em florestas pode nos
prejudicar nossa vida social e pessoal
primeiro foi irei falar sobre o oxigênio
que é algo ligado com a nossa vida
social pois o oxigênio além de nos dar
vida também consegue mudar nosso humor
para bom humor
o mau humor por exemplo quando você
acorda em campos
você acorda feliz e com disposição para
a vida pois o ar das árvores é mais puro
e se deixa melhor você se sente melhor e
tem uma disposição para a vida
mas quando você acorda cidade você
acorda bravo
você acorda com aquele ar poluído e já
pensa em tentar acordar agora mesmo pois
você acorda em locais como esse ninguém
merece acordar com buzina de carro né
mas os campos também estão começando a
sofrer pois os seus filhos estão ficando
muito poluídos
isso está prejudicando eles e também nos
prejudicando
você pensa assim aquele vizinho não tem
nada a ver comigo então você passa a ver
poluído sentido na hora e depois esquece
mas aquele riozinho pode estar ligado
com locais na cidade que sejam muito
importantes para a nossa vida
isso pode acabar incluindo cada vez mais
agora irei falar sobre enchentes que é
algo que impacto na nossa vida pessoal
por exemplo nós temos poucas aves na
nossa cidade e nós temos muitos prédios
e casas
e quando nós temos poucas árvores as
árvores em um solo que conseguem segurar
água e como as enchentes vem o sol
segura mas como nós temos poucas árvores
só vai segurar um pouquinho e vai direto
para casas e prédios
enchente tem relação com o mosquito da
dengue vocês sabiam disso e enchentes
contém duas doenças
a leptospirose que a doença transmitida
pelo rato e também transmitida pela
urina pelas fezes
ela tem a capacidade de mann de se matar
ea e também tem a ver com o mosquito da
dengue
no caso da dengue que pode deixar com
febre alta e também é capaz de matar
pois os mosquitos conseguem se
reproduzir melhor em águas sujas em
águas paradas pois as enchentes elas
ficam muito tempo parados nos que
conseguem se reproduzir melhor mas serve
sobressai são locais onde existam têm
eles estão tentando melhorar a nossa
vida pois eu tenho uma lei que proíbe
proíbe mesmo que eles destruam
no caso das matas mas tem pessoas que
não conseguem driblar essa lei e
deixando esses locais
assim a gente não quer que o nosso mundo
fiquei assim cheio de poluição e com
pouco solo fértil
então vamos contribuir para a
preservação fazendo a nossa parte
ligue 190 polícia ambiental quando você
vê alguma pessoa de blanco uma lei nova
se coloca em suas redes sociais
a praça só saberem o que está
acontecendo isso acontecendo e ficarem
cientes
obrigado